han pasado tan solo cuatro días desde
que víctor orbán ganará las elecciones
con una aplastante victoria aunque
organizaciones como la otan ha advertido
que no se produjeron en igualdad de
condiciones pero viktor orbán sigue
tensando la cuerda con bruselas igual
que lo ha hecho en los últimos años
declaró en su discurso de victoria que
las instituciones europeas son sus
rivales pero también el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski porque éste
le afeó en público sus relaciones con el
kremlin por si esto no fuera poco el
secretario general de la otan james
tótem ber tuvo que llamarle ayer al
orden a viktor orbán y recordarle la
unidad inquebrantable de la alianza
frente a rusia y en un apoyo claro a
ucrania aún así víctor orbán quiere ir
un paso más allá ha asegurado que no
descarta pagar en rublos el gas de rusia
a pesar de que es algo que se ha
rechazado por parte de los países
europeos y también del g7 hay que
recordar que hungría es muy dependiente
del gas y del petróleo de rusia y
precisamente por ello ya ha advertido
que bloqueará cualquier posibilidad de
que haya un embargo del petróleo y del
gas de rusia por parte de la unión
europea además todo esto se suma que la
comisión europea esta misma semana por
primera vez ha activado el mecanismo que
podría dejar a hungría sin fondos
europeos por una sistemática vulneración
del estado de derecho
todo esto está complicando mucho las
relaciones entre budapest y bruselas la
unión europea teme que viktor orbán
sintiéndose más fuerte que nunca después
de estas elecciones e intente poner en
jaque la unidad de la unión europea
mostrada hasta ahora ante rusia